[Applaudissements]
bonjour je vais essayer d'être un peu
plus léger que les deux premières
présentations va même essayer de
s'envoler le thème aujourd'hui c'est au
delà des horizons et malheureusement
d'ici on voit rien au delà de l'horizon
la définition de l'horizon je vous
propose qu'on y aille ensemble qu'on
fasse un petit bout de route ensemble
en échange de ce petit bout de route je
vous promets je vous fais une promesse
ce petit bout de route ensemble va vous
rendre enthousiaste enthousiaste comme
enfant quand vous ouvriez vos cadeaux de
noël
souvenez vous prenez quelques secondes
laissez vos yeux se mettre à pétiller
souvenez-vous être enthousiaste c'est
bon nous voici ensemble notre route
comment s'asseoir divers vous êtes seul
dans votre voiture vous êtes seul sur la
route
la neige s'accumule vous glissez vous
retrouver dans le banc de neige
rien de grave je vous passe les jurons
vous savez déjà que vous aurez besoin d'
aide pour repartir
vous appelez pour avertir de votre
retard et là surprise c'est votre grand
mère au téléphone quand vous lui dites
où vous vous trouvez elle vous dit
t'inquiètes pas j'ai une amie dans le
village juste à côté elle connaît tout
le monde
je l'appelle je lui dirai que tu offres
offrira une des bonnes bouteilles de vin
que tu avais prévu d'amener ça ne va pas
traîner
effectivement
voilà quelqu'un qui arrive et le temps
de le dire vous voilà reparti vous dites
finalement aujourd'hui c'est mon jour de
chance vous avez redécouvert la
puissance d'avoir des amis communs est
quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas
quelqu'un qui peut vous aider facilement
et spontanément quelqu'un qui peut vous
rendre un grand service
voulant continuer à garder ce bon
feeling de ce moment magique vous vous
remémorez votre dernière mésaventure
avec un banc de neige ce matin là vous
sortiez et vous avez découvert que le
chasse neige avait enseveli votre
voiture
énervé pressé d'être entré vous changez
vous est ressorti bien le thé pendant
une heure vous être rentré pris une
douche
vous êtes arrivé au bureau avec deux
heures de retard vous dit sorry
ressembler à quoi si ça avait été mon
jour de chance
si par exemple quand j'avais appelé mon
patron il m'avait dit ne t'inquiète pas
je connais un gars qui n'ont faut pas
exagérer faut pas pousser mémé dans les
orties votre patron il connaît pas un
gars qui va se faire un plaisir de
pelleter à votre place pour ceux qui
connaissent pas l'expression pousser
mémé dans les orties c'est simplement
faut pas exagérer je reprends votre
patron vous dis je connais un gars qui
va passer en voiture devant toi
d'ici deux minutes j'en connais un autre
qui s'en vient au bureau ils vont se
croiser ils vont s'organiser pour tanner
rapidement tu vas même arrivés en avance
ouais ça sort était plus qu'un jour de
chance ça serait un jour de l'auto si
c'était arrivé seriez précipité acheter
un billet
qu'at-il de si différent avec le premier
scénario les deux gars en voiture existe
probablement il ya bien une voiture qui
est passé devant vous qui allez dans la
bonne direction elle en a sûrement
croisé une autre
sans aller au bureau c'est de les
attraper au vol qui est improbable
c'est d'orchestrer la collaboration en
temps réel qui est difficile si vous
aviez dû avoir des amis communs capable
d'organiser quelque chose comme ça il
faudrait qu'il soit dans une tour de
contrôle en communication avec vous en
permanence et là eurêka vous avez une
intuition joies vos yeux pétiller bon
feeling enthousiasme je reprends est là
eurêka vous avez une intuition
pourquoi ne pas propulser nos amis de la
tour de contrôle dans les nuages
on ne pousse pas mémé dans les orties
on la propulse dans les nuages
c'est sans danger c'est juste pour vous
dire que nos amis communs pourraient
être virtuel
imaginez des amis communs virtuel juste
là pour nous aider à collaborer serait
ce possible
aujourd'hui entre les objets connectés
la g5
il pourrait très père connecter à bhl
entre avec nous même si nous étions
nombreux avec l'intelligence
artificielle ils pouvaient coordonner
nos canaux collaboration même si elles
étaient complexes avec le calcul
quantique il pourrait orchestrer des
millions de collaboration en temps réel
avec les blocs chaîne il pourrait
transiger pour s'assurer que tout le
monde soit certain d'être gagnant avec
la modélisation 3d la virtualisation
il pourrait nous montrer ce que nous
devrions faire pour qu'on puisse le
faire au mieux en fonction de nos
contraintes et de nos capacités
ouais ça fait beaucoup de technologies
c'est vrai
hier elles n'existaient pas hier encore
c'était pas possible aujourd'hui elles
existent elles existent tout
alors oui aujourd'hui on peut créer des
amis virtuels les amis communs virtuel
vous propose qu'on les appelle des amis
cole jusque là traduction deux amis en
espéranto
est ce que ces amicaux vont changer
quelque chose à notre vie essayons de
voir ce qui pourrait se passer
imaginez là que j'ai ma gourde
puisqu'elle est vide
puis là que j'ai bien soif de vous
parler je peux pas partir puis à les
remplir ma gourde
c'est un peu embêtant mais je pourrais
demander à mon ami cols que tu vois que
quelqu'un me donne un coup de main pour
que ça se passe
et oui mon ami qu il pourrait voir que
julie tout en haut est en train de
sortir et qu'elle est aussi en train
d'aller remplir sa gourde et oui elle
pourrait au passage à les remplir la
mienne donc les amicaux y seront
organisées pour ça si ça se passait ben
ça serait mon jour de chance c'est comme
quand je suis sorti du banc de neige
mais julie qui est en haut
peut-être envie d'écouter ce que je
raconte elle a pas envie de descendre
ici de prendre la bouteille et de
retourner mais là mon admis qu il
pourrait voir que jean françois qui est
juste là devant moi pourrait attraper la
bouteille la faire passer derrière que
ma bouteille circulent qu'on la donne à
lui que julie la remplissent là c'est
toute une armée d'amico qui se serait
orchestrée en temps réel pour que ma
bouteille circulent là on est dans le
deuxième cas de figure
organiser des choses en temps réel donc
s'arrêter mon jour de l'auto
moi aujourd'hui je sais pas ce que vous
pouvez faire pour moi je sais pas à quoi
vous êtes occupé aujourd'hui je connais
pas votre disponibilité
j'aurais pas tant ces a demandé à mon
ami coq d'organiser tout ça mais mon ami
cole qui voit que ma bouteille évident
qu'ils voient que ma langue et pâteuse
pourrait se dire je vais l'organiser
pour ian lui d'organiser que
jean-françois la presse que je vois tout
d'un coup jean françois prend de la
bouteille que ma bouteille samba of paf
elle revient waouh l'état mis qu ils
peuvent être prévenir c'est pas
simplement quand moi j'ai un besoin
exprimé eux peuvent venir au devant de
moi ça sort était mon jour de fête
troisièmement il se pourrait que cloué
sur le bord elle est aussi sa bouteille
vide et que les amicaux et en discutant
voit très bien que au passage en faisant
circuler les bouteilles on pouvait
changer le parcours de ma bouteille il
ramasse et celle de chloé et de remplir
la bouteille de clouer au passage et là
il ne s'agit plus du tout de savoir si
nos amis comme mes amies comme nos amis
qu ils peuvent m'aider c'est de voir
comment nous pouvons collaborer
intelligemment et solidairement ensemble
ça si on leur organise ça serait notre
jour de gloire
imaginez ça dans les circonstances que
vous voulez
collaborer vivre en collaborant
intelligemment et solidairement nous
avons baptisé ça la révolution citoyenne
nous pourrons collaborer intelligemment
solidairement en restant libres de nos
choix et gagnant de participer avec la
co évolution citoyenne ça sera jour de
chance jour de l'auto jours de fête
jour de gloire tous les jours imaginez
l'impact que sera sur la société
vous vous demandez qui va organiser ça
évidemment ça peut être les
gouvernements peuvent pas se mêler de la
façon dont on va collaborer satis et les
entreprises qui les organisent oui on va
collaborer pour leurs actionnaires
il faut que la co évolution citoyenne
reste citoyenne aujourd'hui il ya des
centaines de citoyens venus de tous les
horizons qui se regroupent dans les
médias sociaux
ces enthousiastes de la première heure
ont décidé de privilégier les transports
pourquoi nous coûte une fortune
il nous faut gaspiller un temps
absolument énorme n'est pas uniquement
pour ça ces enthousiastes de la première
heure ont réalisé que à des claques aux
évolutions citoyenne nous avions
gaspillé beaucoup moins que nous allions
adopté les innovations durables
rapidement que nous allons pouvoir voir
envisager la décroissance en augmentant
notre bien-être
ils ont réalisé quelques claques aux
évolutions citoyenne nous pourrions
faire la transition écologique
rapidement c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
choisi les transports parce qu'ils sont
aussi une source d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre très importante
ces enthousiastes de la première heure
sont ainsi doublement enthousiaste parmi
ces derniers il ya ceux qui
m'accompagnent aujourd'hui vous avez
remarqué je suis pas vraiment tout seul
sur scène ces artistes ont joué le rôle
d'amy commun maison était aussi pendant
cette présentation des amis communs
entre vous et moi
aujourd'hui ils sont déjà sur le point
de scénariser un film
pour montrer la coalition citoyenne et
vous savez quoi
ça les rend triplement enthousiaste et
bien si l'entousiasme et le carburant
qui nous propulse au delà des horizons
et que d'avancer en produits nous y
serons demain
merci
[Applaudissements]